We'll start off with executive producer, Jason Rothenberg
She plays Clarke, Eliza Taylor please
He plays Bellamy,  Bob Morley
He plays Bellamy, Bob Morley
She plays Octavia, please welcome, Marie Avgeropoulos
Can't call him Chancellor anymore
But, he's still Jaha, please welcome Isaiah Washington.
If you need a mechanic, you know to call Raven
Please welcome, Lindsey Morgan
And, last but not least, please welcome the man
who plays Lincoln, Ricky Whittle
So, a lot to talk about her, guys
I'm gonna ask questions for a litlle bit
Jason, you know season 10...season 2
something is going on with Jaha right now
What can you say going in the season 3
You know how what begin
Ark in the season 3 be in a...in a proud in that show
Um okay well to start with a spoiler
We are going to I have a first time..... between seasons
We gonna pick things up a little weird time after
After Clarke built on people
And the season its half is gonna be....
I think it's different from season 2 and season 1 was from season 2
Obviously... you know the A.L.L.I.E story, the A.I story
You know much more. I think science fiction direction
We started the show with the Sci-Fi's
You know really hard corner sci-fi's show
We were in space. Obviously we lost that and really missed that
Really intense hard corner sci-fi's
Eliza you know Clarke she had to do
at the end of season 2
Yeahh..
And... yeah she basically said she couldn't be there at the end
She had to take off after what happened
She is finding herself
She's finding herself !!
What do you think her friend of mind of this point
I mean are she...are she damange or is it just the wait of it  ?
Um no she's a... she's I mean what she did at the end of the season was so...udge and traumatic
And I think that she's running away which is very unclarke like